das game content ziehen soll
[Musik]
freunde hier zu einem wie vorhin in dem
video versprochenen noch kleinen spiel
was ich spiele wenn man spiel nennen
kann ich hole immer im kurzen china run
damit er das ganze sauber macht und zwar
ist das direktor reihe und zwar gibt es
david jost wird chuck baker computers
mac-computer kickers alles so weg sachen
also wie man jemanden der über allem
steht umbringen kann ich freu mich hat
nicht jeder dass das jetzt so wurde in
der letzten folge empfohlen hey mach
doch mal weg wie sie das alles und ich
dachte ja das ist zeichentrick so
schlimm kann das gar nicht sein habe ich
mich wohl getäuscht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
warnung aus schreibe ich hätte nie
gedacht dass sie so viel blut gezeigt
wird in deutschland wäre so etwas direkt
wieder gesperrt worden
können wir dennoch nehmen aber irgendwie
interessant hier der golfschläger sieht
wenn man ganz interessant aus platin
doch nicht noch mehr alter mann
was ist das für ein spiel alter das ist
doch war das kann man dann noch nehmen
kommen wir nehmen jetzt mal den pott
[Musik]
kommen wir immer die uhr wie er dem
album bringt es echt was ist das game
content scenes of silence and gold holt
studio seines klosters game now
[Musik]
ich dachte echt man könnte in diesem
spiel irgendwie bisschen mehr machen mir
hatte usern die kommentare geschrieben
haymarket player hat mal weg gemacht
macht es da aber weil wir stimmt witzig
was ist hier an witzig dieses fucking
spiel ist einfach nur mega brutal hätte
ich glaube das ist echt die erste szene
ohne dass irgendein typ dabei jetzt
irgendwie drauf geht oder was passiert
jetzt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wieso war das klare schauen was der
kleine junge jetzt macht die
unvorhersehbar
ich kann die taschenlampe von ihm nehmen
dann schauen was ich damit jetzt
anrichten kann
[Musik]
ich komme auch klar wieso empfiehlt ich
mir so ein zugang zu land steht das kann
doch nicht sein dass über dem ganzen
spiel
dieses game content in st
alles war nur erkannt und es tut mir
leid dieses videos locker es ab 18
freigegeben
das kann auch nicht sein was ist denn
das für ein spiel
ach so was ich will nicht wissen was
passiert wenn ich jetzt die schere
auswählen freude ich bin raus ich bin
dass es nicht wahr
das kann nicht wahr sein wieso empfiehlt
man mir so ein spiel luca kannst du dass
man sagen kann man nicht verstehen
freunde ich würde sagen das war's mit
diesem video
ich dachte ich könnte mehr machen in dem
spiel aber irgendwie konnte ich gar
nichts machen wenn es euch trotzdem
gefallen da würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen wenn ihr weitere spiele
kennt die mir eventuell gefallen könnten
dann schreibt mir die kommentare
[Musik]